my boy is dead but that's life Merry
Christmas the blood of Christ
you sent karaoke at your son's funeral
why can't you sing baby it's cold
outside anymore what the [ __ ] is going
on can you have a baby ready so we can
take it to Wendy's I'm not having a
child so you can take it to Wendy's
would you eat your ass I would let took
a course and strap you to a table and
violently assault me some woman at the
bank was telling me that Jesus Christ
was a refugee I said Jesus was not an
illegal immigrant no he wasn't so you
guys got me nothing for Christmas you're
getting a very special gift that my
great-grandfather left to me it was a
cigarette holder used by Hitler baby
it's cold outside
hit me in the face your son is dead my
Christmas wish is to name a boat after
my son I love boats too either of you
care about anything except [ __ ] going
on cruises and eat it I don't wanna
is Christmas I just want a boat named
after my dad son it's Christmas time
it's Christmas time